F*ck them. No, we don't need money.
♪ indy rock ♪
[Russian]
Off, leaving Bishkek, going to Almaty
and here is the process.
I'm in a taxi now
but we're going to another taxi
and you get a shared car,
basically, with a driver.
Once it fills up with people, you leave.
-Da? (Yes)
-Da.
-Okay.
And she's helping me.
She's helped me
find the right guy and negotiate
because if you don't know the prices,
you most likely....
Most likely get screwed.
So I asked her to do
some negotiation for me.
[Russian]
They're connected like aspen trees.
Everybody knows everybody.
Sometimes there's infighting,
sometimes they help each other out.
So that was pretty easy.
He said go to this guy.
[Russian]
Nobody's on this ride and I gotta get
to the airport in Almaty at...
I gotta be there by 5:30.
So if we do leave in two hours
like he said is possible
that's no-go,
that's a missed flight situation.
I thought there would be
many, many people but...
There aren't.
So we gotta fill this thing up.
We gotta fill the van up and then we go.
[Russian]
-Thank you.
-Almaty?
Zamir, he's a class guy.
-Good evening, good evening.
Good afternoon.
-Zamir was going for
the hard sale in the beginning
but then he really warmed up.
I feel like we got a good driver.
[Russian]
Zamir just offered me a deal.
He said he'll drive me alone
to the airport in Almaty for $65.
It's roughly five hours, the drive
and I love the experiences
of filling the car up
and connecting with random people
but I definitely messed this situation up
and came too late this morning.
So don't do that
if you're going Bishkek to Almaty.
From what he's saying,
do it early in the morning.
I'm gonna take Zamir's offer.
-Zamir...
-Zamir. [chuckles]
-Okay.
-He's pumped, he doesn't have to wait
and he gets the full price.
Yeah, off to the border.
-[chuckling] Okay.
-Just for the record, the Kyrgys do
drive a little mad I will say.
It feels very peaceful on the streets
but I feel like
all the aggression is let out
behind the steering wheel
and the gas pedal.
Zamir's trying to
poke through this intersection.
[honking]
Nice, Zamir.
[Russian]
Getting close to the Kazakh border
and I made the fatal mistake
of giving money first.
He wanted it all and I gave him half.
So I got a weird feeling right now
there's a bit of a scam going on.
As in I don't see him
on the other side of the border
'cause I gotta go through customs,
he's gotta go through with his car.
So this should be interesting.
I got a weird feeling.
Normally always give money
at the end with a taxi driver.
It's like I always do that
and since we don't have
anyone in the vehicle, I thought,
"Well, he needs some gas money,
I'll give him half up front."
I wasn't really on my A game.
So we'll see if I see
Zamir on the other side.
Right beyond that flag is Kazakhstan.
I got that totally wrong.
I thought...
I thought he was scamming me and he's not.
It's really cool
but I've heard of a lot of people
getting scammed at this border.
And so I do have a history here.
I have a very interesting history.
[Russian]
-Okay.
-Sixteen years ago
I was traveling with a friend of mine.
I was traveling with a friend of mine
and we got to the other side
and I lost him, his name's Gavin.
And we were with a shared taxi,
many people in it
and we didn't know where he went.
We waited for like an hour
and so this one lady,
this very tough, authoritative-type woman
went looking for him.
Well, we all went looking for him
but then she found him in a car.
In the back of a car
with this smoking hot woman.
"It was like a super model." he said,
and two militzia, two policemen.
And they were trying to
extract money out of him.
So they wouldn't let him leave the car
but he said it was
this interesting situation
where he was in the back of car
with a smoking hot woman
and, you know,
they're just sort of hanging out.
So that was 16 years ago here.
I think things have cleaned up quite a bit.
From my experiences so far
in these two countries, this trip
it's way easier to get around.
Okay... [Russian] It's all good?
-Yeah.
-That's how you say your name, Sheshwan?
-Jazwan.
-Jazwan?
-Just call me Jess.
-Jazwan.
A very friendly border agent, Jazwan.
16 years ago I came through here
and it was totally different.
[chuckles]
-This is real progress, haha.
-Seriously, bro.
-Yeah.
-My friend was, like,
held hostage over there.
Seriously, two militzia guys
put him in the back of the car,
wanted money and they had, like,
a super model back there in the car too.
[hands slap]
-Have a nice trip.
-All right, bro.
Kazakhstan is definitely
much different this time coming in.
Take care, bro.
Very cool, I mean I've never been
to a border where they've said,
"Yeah, put your camera up
and take footage if you want."
It's so cool to see
the changes in the world.
Like, everything's always changing.
It's either getting better or worse.
I would say this border into Kazakhstan,
in general, is on the much better trend.
In as far as letting tourists in.
Before, it was super hard to get visas.
It was a pain in the ass.
You needed to do all this documentation
and now it's simple, no visa,
just write on a little piece of paper
and go through in 10 minutes.
There's Zamir. Zamir's calling me.
Zamir...
[Russian]
All is good.
♪ Kazakh music on the radio ♪
200 kilometers, 120 miles from Almaty.
Not much between the two cities.
Just wide, expansive spaces.
Highway stop for lunch.
Probably the coolest looking money.
Kazakh... What is it? Tenge.
[Russian]
I was thinking the local restaurants
they have off the main road.
He just brought me to
a truck stop-type place.
[door closes]
Okay.
Off for a little dining experience, guys.
Roadside cafe.
Middle of nowhere, Kazakhstan.
[Peter exhales]
[Russian]
Chicken, no? No chicken.
MAN: Cheese.
PETER: Cheese, okay.
[Russian]
No way.
He's got a visa to the US, cool.
[Russian]
California.
Guys, I'm not gonna lie.
This is very difficult,
uncomfortable shooting... footage to get.
The reason I'm doing it
is 'cause I want to bring you in
close to the action,
close to the real life,
close to the hospitality.
I always talk about it,
I always try to explain it to people
but it's one thing to talk,
another thing to show.
So that's the whole reason
but it's really uncomfortable
'cause some people
obviously don't want
a camera on their face.
Which is totally understandable.
[Russian]
Big or small?
Big, big...
[Russian]
Two big ones.
So what I was saying is...
[coughs]
Some people really don't like
the camera in their face.
So it's this crazy balance of
getting it up to the people that don't mind
and hiding it from the people that do mind.
And, like, the woman...
She...
The woman that worked there,
she didn't want the camera up.
So I had to take it down,
it was a little uncomfortable.
But again, the whole reason
is just show you guys the real life.
It's my mission to show
true, authentic moments.
So I hope that worked.
I had to put the camera down a bunch.
Okay... [Russian]
[Russian]
Very delicious food.
It was like an empanada.
Basically what it was,
I don't know the name.
What's very interesting
in this part of the world
is the Soviet Union
comprised of 15 countries
and there's some sameness about them
but they also have
their own unique identities.
So the "stan" countries,
there's five of them
and they’re all different
but there's some Russification feeling
that you feel in all of them.
And then you can go to Estonia
and that's a completely different world.
It's much more European.
[honking]
So after traveling
in this part of the world long enough
you come to realize it's crazy
it stayed together as long as it did.
Because it has so many cultures,
such expansive territory,
so many languages.
So many different languages
were in the former Soviet Union.
Are in the former Soviet Union.
So...
What did it last, 70-ish odd years?
I don't know how it kept together.
because Kazakhstan and Kyrgyzstan
have a lot of similarities.
They're different, but then you take
Kazakhstan and Estonia or Georgia
and those are different worlds completely.
Uh...
No, no, no... Nyet, nyet, nyet...
[Russian]
Yeah, it's really fascinating.
This part of the world is often overlooked
and for me, it's one of my favorites,
if not my favorite.
Because it's not at all
what we were taught, for sure.
Like, we were taught Moscow.
The look was gray apartment buildings
and skies in Moscow.
It wasn't massive mountains
and different cultures, that's for sure.
And so there's the process
of passing trucks where he can't see
what's around the truck and I can
and it's been an interesting experience
of him pulling out
and me seeing something oncoming.
Okay, da, da.
[Zamir speaking Russian]
We just got into Almaty and another city
where the mountains just [woosh].
Kick out of it.
Almaty, roughly 2 million people.
You can't see here
on this street in this area
but it's, in general,
much better off financially than Bishkek.
You can feel it and that's because
they have lots of oil and lots of gas.
And though I've heard it's quite corrupt,
some of that filters down
into the city, into the infrastructure.
Zamir... [Russian]
-Uh-huh.
[Russian]
-Okay.
[hands slap]
[Russian]
WhatsApp, okay.
Phew.
Okay, guys,
if you like that, please subscribe.
I'm gonna be doing a show on Almaty,
a show on Bishkek,
and some other ones in Kyrgyzstan.
And those are
my fully-edited videos with music
and they're really packaged together.
This is more of my unfiltered,
just random, what I run into.
Not much editing stuff so...
Thanks for coming along,
hope you liked that.